[Music]
br
the discovery of oil has revived Vena
wher claims to the so-called Guyanese
esba the territory west of the eso River
this is no less than 2third of present
day Guyana it is not surprising that
Guyana has offered good conditions to
both the US giant Exxon Mobile and the
Chinese State Corporation in order to
get them on its side in this conflict so
everything indicates that Guyana will be
able to enjoy unprecedented wealth
thanks to the oil discovered by this
consort now the question is how much
potential money are we talking about
exactly well let's take a
look
giant it seems visual politic viewers
that the oil reserves discovered are so
large that they promised to provide
Guyana with now hold on to your chair
approximately 160 billion dollars with a
B over the next 20 years check it out it
will undoubtedly be a massive change for
a country country where more than 40% of
its 800,000 inhabitants live in abject
poverty on less than $550 a day and
we're not talking about a distant dream
in 2022 alone government revenues from
hydrocarbon exploitation will exceed $1
billion US that's about
$1,250 per capita almost 90% of the
government's ordinary income in the
preceding years Guyana will now be able
to realize its goals and become a modern
and prosperous country for example one
of the dreams is to take advantage of
its rivers to build a hydro electric
power plant that will provide the nation
with clean and stable
[Music]
energy the ideal location has been
identified since 1976 and since 1997 the
government of Guyana has had plans to
build it however throughout all the
intervening years there was one thing
missing the $840 million it will cost to
build the Amelia Falls project or
someone interested in putting up all of
the dough in exchange for its
exploitation but now in theory at least
that problem is about to disappear
Guyana will be able to finance it and in
addition its newly buoyant and growing
economy will create demand for the
energy that would make the operation
profitable curiously however the Chinese
company that was awarded the project has
just pulled out this will delay
commissioning Beyond 2027 it's quite a
setback for Guyana but president Ali
maintains that they are not giving up on
the project take a look the independent
review by Norway has pointed to this
project as being good for Guyana being
good for the environment and bringing
greater prosperities so this project
will get on the way it is precisely
because of all the reasons that Ali has
just pointed out that what is puzzling
is that this project is not going to be
undertaken immediately even if it is
through the state electricity company
but I suppose it will be a matter of
budgetary prudence if that is the
reasoning then it is not so
bad in any case a 227 km gas pipeline to
the coast and a natural gas combined
cycle plant in the vicinity of
Georgetown are already under
construction Exon Mobile itself will be
in charge of this which will subtract
the cost from the profits accruing to
Guyana however what there is also money
for as always when the Indo guyane
govern is always the same a real black
[Music]
hole since coming to power in August
2020 ifan Ali's government has made
several Capital injections into the
state-owned guu co sugar company which
is having trouble even paying salaries
it is even working to reopen loss making
plants simply because they are
employment niches for indog GU in the
last 2 years alone public aid granted to
guko has amounted to approximately 30
billion guyan dollars or about1 140
million of course with all the flood of
money expected these seem like nothing
more than crumbs in any case Guyana is
going to change a lot over the next few
years roads ports schools hospitals
Guyana has become the fastest grumm
economy in the world we're talking about
44% in 2020 and 20% in 2021 by 22 the
governments expect 48% growth and even
if we take oil out of the equation
growth almost reaches 8% things are
going better than ever at all levels
government partners with Mount siai hes
Corp to transform guyana's Healthcare
hes Corporation one of guyana's three
oil companies is a major donor to New
York's Mount Si Hospital one of the most
prestigious in the world and has been
influential in getting the organization
involved in modernizing Diana's
Healthcare
[Music]
System other POS positive news coming
from the Consortium is the driving
effect that its activity has on guyana's
industry it is true that it could be
greater because there are areas that
local companies are currently unable to
reach as the country has so far lacked
heavy industry but there is something
take a look gye suppliers profit from
Exon Mobile's $540 million us
expenditure so $540 million may not seem
much considering Exxon Mobile's total
spending on this project but it is not
bad relative to guyana's GDP in 2021
which was 6.5 billion
what's more Exon Mobile success in
Guyana leaves the country in a better
position to negotiate more beneficial
terms with future investors because no
one doubts the potential of guyana's oil
fields anymore however the country's
ability to attract investment will
depend on its ability to offer legal
certainty and that requires political
stability if they succeed Guyana could
become something like the Monaco of
Latin America but now the question is
over to you what future do you foresee
for Guyana what do you think it should
do with the oil money you can leave me
your answers in the comments and as
always if you found the video
interesting please please like it and
don't forget to subscribe to visual
politic all the best I'll see you next
[Music]
time